Thanks, Dan. As mentioned earlier,
we'll be using Android Studio
throughout this course.
It's an IntelliJ -based IDE
that is optimized specifically
for Android development.
It's still in beta development,
so your version may look
slightly different, but that's okay.
The core functionality should
still be the same.
If you haven't installed it yet,
take a moment to do that now
using the detailed instructions
provided in the link below.
You'll also need to install
the support library
and that's also included
in the instructions.
Note that the SDK
is included automatically,
so you don't need
to install that separately.
If you're having difficulties,
no worries at all.
We totally understand
because it can be tricky
to get everything set up properly.
You can search online for people
who have a similar issue,
or there's a troubleshooting link
included below.
If you still need help,
you can ask a question
in our discussion forum as well.
Once you install it, open it
and you can check for updates
before proceeding.
Check this box when you're done.